a five-hour drive north of sudan's
capital khartoum leads you to one of
this massive country's epicenters of a
multi-billion dollar gold sector
but bloomberg has found through
interviews with local miners government
officials and experts much of that
wealth leaves the country informally
smuggled across borders by land or air
or extracted by informal miners is
packed into bags and ferried in battered
trucks to depots where laborers smash it
up with hammers and deposit it into
rudimentary milling machines
the remaining tailings are transported
to commercial plants many of which have
close ties to sudan's armed forces for
further processing
some of the output is trucked several
hundred miles to the sudanese capital
where it changes hands in a dank
six-storey building downtown
men melt rough nuggets into bars cooling
the molten metal in large tubs of water
and dealers can be seen exiting the
premises carrying piles of cash
according to sudan's finance ministry
official output in the country
represents only a fifth of what was
mined meaning that 80 of gold exports go
unregistered and leave the country
informally
sudan is not the only country struggling
with large-scale gold smuggling
reporting carried out by bloomberg
across africa shows the scale of the
smuggling spanning some dozen countries
and involving tons of gold spirited over
borders in operations often overseen by
armed groups or soldiers according to
one united nations expert illegal
exports from east africa alone amount to
billions every year
its main destination is dubai whose
processing firms stand accused of
facilitating the illicit trade by
closing its eyes to imports from dubious
sources
united arab emirates strenuously denies
any involvement in illegal practices but
as global scrutiny over corporate
governance intensifies the extent of the
smuggling now underway poses
increasingly awkward questions for dubai
and its reputation as a gold trading hub
[Music]